why do you think exactly and so I'm not
telling you what they can
right I'm out here trying to say that
people should have been right to shoot
people with uteruses because trans
people have universes too and they also
deserve the right to choose you should
not be able to force someone to carry a
pregnancy to term and they don't want to
so you're neutrally turning people away
he's our house Oh trees
thank you so much you got it for free
that's it right no I think because I
have inserted tickets because of grant I
can show you right listen I grew up very
on a be like household right I grew up
not knowing that people are going to die
because of what you're doing right if
you have a direct action in which you
are trying to force people with uterus
is to carry pregnancies to term and that
can be medically dangerous you have the
right to not think that abortion is
great but you do not have the right
[Music]
but you that's your choice your idea
so do you support the Missouri yes and
why do you support them because I don't
think I think
that is not scientific biology you say
it's called biology okay did you just
artless straight up lying like none of
this makes any sense
that's saying life begins at conception
are you religious but you are very
religious you just in this on the
souvenir question right so your
religious belief it's that life begins
to conception in Judaism which is the
religion that came before Christianity
that you came from right gonna be
involved is different from Judaism right
it's all Abrahamic it's called theology
Jewish people don't believe that life
begins at conception or right Muslim
people don't believe that life begins at
conception your Christian belief is that
life begins at conception which is
really hurry back in the 80s leave the
Baptist Convention's actually supported
put the Catholic Church the Catholic
Church actually have abortions when the
priests knock them off so in the
Catholic Church itself is actually
pro-abortion when it benefits them but
Catholic Academy there - with you
[Music]
just a much greater misstep up
it's a very good thing the Catholic
Church believed in historical criticism
since the sixties but since Vatican 2 so
knows art they're not real story any
extra is Adam and Eve yeah Walker
Vatican - not cool place yeah no he does
rather frequently Pope Benedict actually
knocked out
it's not community what you said [ __ ]
dr. James old time photo Benedictines
and pretty fresh off your barrel I know
I said that very poorly
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
you can keep trying sir thank you
[Music]
[Music]
it doesn't matter if you're saying
right and listen you know that you have
a seat
[Music]
[Music]
no more batteries
you know what to mention what when the
priests are going the other barista
confessed their child rape
shooting video
[Music]
[Music]
records you didn't release because in
Pennsylvania has the same thing the
records they were these were priests the
routes at the turbo statute limitations
states like New York are actually trying
to route
that statute in place acknowledging that
engine core tubes naturally
joining the cabinet church is actively
putting your votes the lawyers to please
and a lobby against the Catholic Church
has to do a unstable person doesn't mean
that they supported they paid for nuns
to get abortions because the priest
knocked them up wanted to hide it the
Catholic Church
[Music]
down
[Music]
[Music]
no I mean the evidence of the pedophiles
it is a hundred percent there right
[Music]
oh hey how are you